Звук пропадал.
Какие здесь основные показатели существуют? Приемистость – это объем закачки скважину за единицу времени.
И само по себе это не определяет сразу эффективные закачки.
Эффективность закачки определяется по добывающему фонду скважины.
То, что скважина у нас принимает воду, это по сути решение только одной из проблем, когда мы разгружаем товарный парк.
А когда мы смотрим все-таки участок, что и правильно делать, в принципе, и для человека, и для спирта, и для агентов,
то здесь следует учитывать такие показатели, как компенсация.
Это соотношение закачки и отбора жидкости в пластовых условиях.
То есть сколько мы отобрали, сколько мы закачали.
Это как раз целевая, можно сказать, функция по матбалансу для агента, который стремится максимально закачать воду.
Сразу пытаюсь вам такие направления дать, чтобы сберечь время, потому что когда строишь агентов сетями,
между ними обязываешь, первое, что пытается сделать агент, это разогнать максимум свою скважину,
если ты на летательную закачку в закачку, добывающую в добывающую, забойку в минимальную, на летательную максимальную закачку.
Вот эти вещи, чтобы учитывать, сразу резать нужны компенсации.
Во-первых, есть у меня вода с физическим ограничением, а потом уже геологическим,
то с учетом того, чего мы говорили про макронеоднородность, про фазовую проницаемость,
ну и про, в принципе, направление фронтового теснения.
Такое тоже является ключевым.
И как мы оцениваем закачку?
Здесь мы ее оцениваем в адресном отклике.
То есть здесь, когда мы закачиваем, мы, допустим, на одной нагнетательной начинаем закачивать воду,
закачка пошла, на ближайшее добывающее мы начинаем ловить от нее отклики.
И формируем дальше мы сеть, либо фронт, смотря как вы агентов будете строить и как их обучать.
Но смысл в том, что сразу просто уберечь, наверное, время больше,
не является целевой функцией закачать воду.
Я подробнее скажу еще про основные цели ППД, которые нужно предложить агенту для решения этой задачи.
В принципе, это такие базовые вещи, которые в командах, я думаю, если отрасновики есть, они вам подскажут.
Так, коэффициент использования фонда – это то, что, в принципе, у нас связано со скважинами.
Здесь подробно останавливаться не буду, в принципе, на формулах понятно.
Коэффициент использования – это число действующих скважин ко всем скважинам, которые есть.
Коэффициент эксплуатации – это время работы скважины фактическое, но календарное, которое, в принципе, есть.
Здесь как раз идет учет времени работы скважины с учетом простоев, ремонтов, нестабильности режима, циклика и всего прочего.
Иногда выгодно циклировать высокобводненную скважину.
Ну, это как подсказка тоже.
И коэффициент текущей компенсации – то, что раньше я рассказывал, когда у нас отбор опережает закачку, либо закачка опережает отбор.
И здесь возникают участки, когда, как она называется, локальная перекомпенсация в жизни.
Таких случаев может и не быть.
Могут у нас случаи быть, когда там нарушения какие-то по скважину возникнут раньше, чем мы перекачаем.
За колонной циркуляции возникло.
Ну, а если все-таки это возникает, то это у нас возникают зоны, где мы просто аномально высокое пластовое давление.
Вот такой фактор возникает в перекачанных зонах.
Но экономически это только нас съедает по проекту.
Теперь про пластовое забойное давление уже говорил, но просто как картинку оставить в памяти, что показывает собой пластовое давление.
Это запас пластовой энергии и характеристика общего состояния объекта разработки.
Забойное давление – это уже характеристика работы конкретно скважины, связанной с ее либо отбором, интенсивностью отбора, либо закачкой.
То есть это давление в зоне тренирования, в зоне интервала перфорации, то есть именно вот здесь.
Почему это различие критично?
Это различие критично для обучения.
Смотря на что будем обучать.
Нагнетательную скважину можно обучать на забойное давление закачки, можно обучать на пластовое.
То есть для этого есть своя чувствительность.
И теперь, что характеризует давление пластовое, характеризует энергетику пласта, давление забойное, локальный режим работы скважины конкретный.
И перепад между ними, между забойным и пластовым, это как раз вызывает движение жидкости.
Либо в одну сторону, либо в другую.
Вот, по простому языку, если.
Так, про компенсацию.
Ангур говорил.
Перейду к целям системы поддержания пластового давления.
Здесь выявил основные четыре цели, которые, в принципе, перед собой держит любой технолог, любой активист или служба, которая занимается планированием технологических режимов на скважинах.
Первое, что мы хотим, управлять фронтовым вытеснением без прорыва воды.
То есть здесь наша задача обеспечить равномерный охват пласта вытеснением и вовлечение запасов без прорыва воды.
То есть вот как на картинке показано, стадия, когда мы начинаем прорывать воду, практически как это в учебнике нарисовано, когда из поршневого мы на языковое обводнение начинаем выходить.
Здесь как раз мы хотим обеспечивать это фронтовый вытеснение равномерно.
Во втором треке разрешено переводить из добывающих нагнетательные скважины.
То есть и в этом случае вот это первая цель, первый пункт системы поддержания пластового давления, он будет очень актуален.
Если начинается разрежение добывающего ряда скважин нагнетательной скважины, новый там под закачку переводят,
то вы в этот момент начинаете вмешиваться напрямую во фронтовый вытеснение.
И здесь эти фронтовые вытеснения нужно уметь управлять.
Вторая цель – это компенсация, то, о чем мы говорили, поддерживать именно этот баланс отбора и закачки таким образом,
чтобы не терять по пластовому давлению и темпам.
То есть это равномерность именно по скважинам нужно соблюдать, по участкам этой компенсации.
И третье – поддержание пластового давления.
То есть это очень связано со вторым пунктом, но это вывел отдельно, потому что у нас есть участки, когда мы...
можем компенсацию держать на уровне единички, а пластовое давление падает.
Эти случаи тоже существуют в практике.
Кейсы их не задавали в явном виде, но они есть, потому что на втором модели есть аквифер.
И четвертое – разгрузка товарных парков в связи с инфраструктурой.
Когда, в принципе, мы товарный парк разгружаем от товарной воды, от воды, которую сбросили с жидкости.
Ну вот эти четыре цели – это, по сути, один общий набор правил и практик,
как агент должен управлять закачкой при подборе режима приема системы, при подборе заводнения.
Так, теперь перейду к следующему слайду – это метод регулирования заводнения.
Как мы можем это делать, как мы можем управлять?
Изменение направления хитрационных потоков.
То есть месторождение будет действующее уже в стадии разработки,
со своими режимами работы скважин,
и тестовое задание будет задаваться уже на уровне третьей стадии разработки,
когда все, в принципе, введено в эксплуатацию.
Поэтому здесь на этих стадиях остановился, не говоря уже о методах заводнения.
Здесь, например, первое, как мы можем управлять фондом –
это изменение фильтрационных потоков.
Самое высокое и эффективное – смене капитала емким вложением,
когда мы можем перераспределять отбор и закачку между скважинами.
Но когда это делает, например, специалист на практике,
это может через многовариантные расчеты производиться на гидрономических моделях,
это может на основе гидропрослушивания,
когда такие эксперименты были в компании.
То есть на уровне экспертного понимания области
человек говорит, там, специалист, гидродинамик или руководитель актива,
что у меня в этой зоне есть предположение на застойную нефть.
И необходимо перераспределить закачку, перераспределить добычу,
ввести в циклику, ну и таким образом он начинает эту застойную зону вырабатывать.
В нашем случае мы это все отдаем агенту, который мы хотим,
чтобы он это все понимал и на этом учился.
Для этого у вас будет модель синтетическая,
которую можно гонять вдоль и поперек по всем режимам,
с целью, чтобы агент начинал понимать физику пласта
с учетом тех ограничений базовые, которые я приводил по фильтрации,
по макбалансам, чтобы агент уже на этом уровне мог понимать,
куда качать эффективно, куда качать неэффективно.
Порсируем отбор жидкости.
То, что хочется сделать в первую очередь, здесь следует учитывать,
что неизбежно резкий рост обладненности.
Прорывы воды связаны с подвижностью воды.
Подвижность по воде высокая, подвижность по нефти низкая.
Вода будет прорываться.
А еще это будет зависеть от той проникцаемости коллектора,
которой у вас будут модели.
То есть это тоже нужно учитывать.
Не везде это будет работать равно и одинаково.
И не на всех стадиях это будет работать.
Здание высокого давления нагнетания.
То, что я об этом уже говорил, это тоже будет вести к тому,
что скважина будет принимать, пока не упрется в забойное давление,
в 300 атмосфер условно, но в модели задано.
Но это не означает о том, что это хорошо.
То есть вода будет уходить по пронесаемым зонам.
Либо в трещину, как это в жизни происходит.
И ключевое ограничение.
Любой из методов, который вот здесь перечислен,
он эффективен, только если сможете и заложите физическое основание расчета.
И именно вот это межскважинную корреляцию,
которую, в принципе, необходимо получить в процессе обучения агентов.
Про причины прорыва воды просто кратко повторю.
Это каналы высокой проводимости.
То есть мы смотрели до этого ОФП по воде, по нефти.
Самый идеальный случай просто нарисовал для поршневого вытянения.
Когда это происходит?
Когда у нас каналы высокой проводимости появляются,
будут трещины, будут разломы.
Заколонки, которые у нас, в принципе,
сразу при определенном градиенте давления принимают воду.
И потом, что еще?
А, про конус не сказал.
Низкое забойное давление быстро подтягивает конус снизу.
То есть я до этого говорил, что у нас вода от нагнетательной скважины может прийти.
В моделях у нас есть вода подошвенная.
Так она и называется.
Вода с аквифера в модели она задана.
Когда мы начинаем резко форсировать отбор жидкости,
при этом нагнетательные скважины могут стоять далеко,
но мы тем самым начинаем подтягивать конус воды снизу.
И тогда уже получим опять воду, но только уже снизу.
Вот эти вещи нужно учитывать.
Это именно наше физико-месторождение, физико-пласта,
которое нам нужно на этом уровне заложить в агент.
Так.
Вот у нас зарядка начинается.
Можем прерваться на 10 минут?
Григорий, слышите, не слышите?
Предлагаю всем сделать пока зарядку,
через 10 минут, когда вернуться.
Потому что, скорее всего, меня будет плохо слышно.
Продолжение следует...
!
Проще производственные...
Какие-то показатели...
Которые нормируются...
По экономике...
И когда вы загружаете показатели...
Там надо будет нажать...
Всего несколько кнопок...
Вот в принципе платформа доступна...
Перетащить...
Рассчитать экономику...
Кнопка нажмется...
Ну и кнопка, например...
Она автоматически перебрасывается...
Сохранить расчет...
То есть если серию расчетов делаете...
То в принципе эти расчеты...
Потом можно будет в конце...
Вот здесь вот уже посмотреть...
Разный набор расчетов...
Как выгоняли их...
И сделать, например...
Какую-то свою аналитику решений...
То есть это я так делал...
Потому что мне нужно было всегда видеть...
Какая скважина меня вытягивает фонд...
Ну это скважина...
Принцип Парета, наверное, знаете...
20% скважины дает 80% результатов...
Вот этот принцип, чтобы учитывать...
И работать именно с зелеными скважинами...
Ну вот отдельная вкладка с аналитикой решений есть...
Тут же есть методика...
Как работает и считается экономика...
То есть в принципе этот файл вам будет передан...
Для того, чтобы вы на нем могли считать...
И в принципе с экономикой вопросов у команд не возникало...
Потому что больше, что требуется от команд в рамках Катона...
Это именно получить рабочий прототип по решению...
Который в принципе был озвучен...
Управленческое решение...
Так, это я весь экран поставлю...
Управленческое решение должно быть одновременно физически реализуемым...
Технологически корректным и экономически оправданным на расчетном горизонте...
Физически реализуемым...
Здесь я как раз про это проговаривал...
То есть...
Что модели, которые будут...
Должны быть построены...
Они не должны являться...
Скажем...
Копией гидродинамики...
Но вот такие случаи есть...
Но возможно это будет один из подходов тоже...
Когда загрузите, например, все кубы с моделей в агента...
И агент просто должен будет, зная все кубы, воспроизвести все численные уравнения...
Уравнения неразрывности...
Уравнения и фильтрации...
Ну то есть мы эту задачу себе не ставим...
Вы, во-первых, и по времени это не сделаете...
Второй симулятор, это навигатор или OPM...
Вы не создадите за это время...
И это будет тупиковая, наоборот, ветка решения...
Потому что вы для себя...
Ну, пойдете по пути воспроизвести симулятор, да?
Здесь же у нас задача научиться аналитически понимать наш объект разработки...
Чтобы потом эти решения тиражировать смогли на производственную практику уже...
Когда мы точно так же берем промысловые показатели...
Но они у нас уже не могут быть сгенерированы в тысячи вариаций разных...
Для этого у нас была модель, которую мы заранее сгенерировали...
А в производственном контуре мы просто подсадили конкретную историю разработки...
Сценарий разработки по скважинам...
Но агенты уже, в принципе, дальше понимают, насколько была садаптирована модель...
Насколько реальная история садится на производственный кейс...
Вот этот вот, который нейросеть смогла получить...
То есть здесь, поэтому история должна быть такой вот...
Физически реализуемой и технологически корректной...
То есть в производственных показателях...
Там какие ограничения заданы, их тоже следует учитывать...
Например, давление в 300 атмосфер на нагнетательных скважин ставили...
Это тоже не просто так...
Потому что выше этого давления на кейсе ничего не произойдет...
В жизни произойдет раскрытие трещины...
Даже на более ранних давлениях в зависимости от типа коллектора...
Где-то 180, где-то 190 даже там может происходить...
То есть высокие давления закачки...
Это тоже не физически реализуемые вещи...
Хотя в модели это все воспроизводится отлично...
Но экономически оправданным...
Все решения, которые будут управляться по закачке...
По логике...
Они должны быть экономически обоснованными...
Но не просто так, что...
Хотя, может быть, вы и доказываете на уровне экономики...
Что, например, надо добыть одну воду...
Чтобы в другом месте эту воду закачать...
Может быть, такое решение тоже будет...
Я не подскажу сейчас...
Но скажу сразу, что штрафуется вода...
Ну, то есть лишняя вода, которая идет в потоке жидкости...
Потому что норматив на жидкость идет...
И норматив на закачку...
То есть потратили деньги, чтобы добыть...
Потратили деньги, чтобы закачать...
Соответственно, эти затраты двойные мы должны откупить...
На ближайшем окружении добывающих скважин...
Как минимум...
С каким-то коэффициентом 1.1, например, по EDD...
Это минимум...
Ну, вот...
На этом, что хотелось бы сказать...
И...
Наверное, заключительным слайд...
Таким оставить...
Все-таки считать объект, связанный системой...
Те, кто подходят к нейросетям...
Ну, специалисты там, кто машинобучения...
Проходили профессиональные...
Обучались на курсах разных...
Сами строили агентов...
Они это понимают...
Что система должна быть связана...
Агенты должны взаимодействовать между собой...
Они должны учитывать физику процесса...
То есть про это и говорили...
Эту физику процесса...
Нужно закладывать сразу в агента...
Как вы это заложите...
То есть это ваш творческий уже потенциал...
Как он будет сделан...
Но, в принципе, эту физику надо будет учитывать...
Потому что в жизни эта физика работает...
Не всегда за нас...
Но иногда и против нас...
Когда мы ее не учитываем...
Соблюдать ограничения...
Которые у нас потом в тестовом кейсе возникнут...
То есть ограничения...
Во-первых, это по давлениям...
Ограничения по фонду...
Ограничения по закачке...
Ну, наверное, все...
Больше таких...
Я на ограничения пока вот не вспомню...
Ну, дополнительно это все будет еще прописано все...
Ну, и работать все-таки на ЧДД...
То есть мы идем на экономику...
Ну, а где нефть, там и экономика...
На этом, коллеги, у меня все...
Спасибо за внимание...
И, в принципе, можем перейти на вопросы...
Так, я вижу...
Константин Попов задал вопрос...
Первый вопрос...
Подскажите...
Ваша модель...
Сиданно синдички нереальные...
Так, про первый вопрос...
Ну, проговорил...
В первом треке...
Модели промысловые данные...
Они синтетические...
Они являются цифровой моделью...
Конкретного там месторождения...
Игрек мы его назвали...
Но ограничение...
Логика ограничения...
Она сформирована по производственным принципам реальным...
То есть это жидкости по лимитам...
По насосам ограничения...
По инфраструктуре...
Так, честные значения ограничения...
Их также следует считать параметрами синтетического кейса...
То есть это не от нефти...
Во втором треке...
То, что объект был реальным...
Но геология была очень сильно перестроена...
Поэтому там тоже полусинтетический...
Но фетка скважин реальная...
А все остальное...
Режимы работы скважин уже сделаны синтетическими...
ОФП учитываем или нет?
Так...
ОФП...
Она у вас уже учитывается в расчете гидродинамической модели...
То есть в физике расчет она уже учитывается...
То есть вы ее не учитывать не сможете...
Почему ее следует...
Учитывать в явном виде...
Так скажем...
Ну, потому что она непосредственно определяет характер утечения нефти водой.
Динамикам в воднености соотношения, подвижности фаз.
Возможно, если у вас в тестовом кейсе...
Не в тестовом кейсе, а в модели, когда вы будете генерировать разные режимы работы скважин,
возможно, вы поймаете в какой-то момент увеличение добычи нефти без увеличения добычи жидкости.
То есть вы поймаете локально невыработанные какие-то зоны, защемленную тупиковую зону какую-то, поймаете случайным образом.
Тогда агент просто это запомнит, направление фронтового теснения, и все себе это оставит.
Почему больше говорил про УФП так детально?
Потому что это, в принципе, стратегия управления режимами работы скважин.
То есть когда мы резко начинаем форсировать, мы резко начинаем ободняться.
То есть здесь как раз для этих вещей это и говорил.
В явном виде, надо ли вам это сдавать или нет?
Я думаю, нет, потому что она у вас есть уже в симуляторе.
Ну, в том симуляторе, в котором вы будете считать.
И там эти данные уже у вас, в принципе, все будут.
Во втором треке суррогатная модель, она тоже должна воспроизводить отклики от гидродинамической модели.
Поэтому влияние УФП там будет учитываться в обучающих данных, но оно не явно будет учитываться.
То есть симулятор уже посчитал это влияние УФП на режимы, на нефть и обводненность.
Ну, а вы просто на этих данных обучились.
Это на этапе прогнозирования, просто когда режим будете сдавать, эти вещи надо будет учитывать.
А отдельно модель УФП строить не надо.
УФП строить не надо.
Так, третий вопрос.
Загрязнение призабойной зоны мы не учитываем.
То есть начальная продуктивность или приемистость, она уже определяется тем состоянием, которое в модели сейчас есть.
То есть все, больше ничего не меняется, скинфактор не меняется, калиматации зоны призабойной нету.
Кислоток и прочего мы здесь не делаем.
Аналогично четвертый вопрос.
ГТМ и да, опускаем.
Ну, классический парк ГТМов, как ГРП, ОПЗ, РИР.
Дострелы, зарезка боковых стволов.
Мы эту задачу не берем.
То есть задача сильно упрощена, задача только управление фондом.
Ну и перевод.
Управление сосредоточено только на режимах работы скважины.
Ну, переключить еще можете добычу в закачку.
Либо открыть, закрыть скважину.
То есть все.
Так, пятый вопрос.
Наклона горизонтальных скважин не будет.
Агенту их учитывать взаимодействие не нужно.
То есть скважины.
Они все полунаклонные, полувертикальные.
То есть, ну, там не сильно наклонные они.
То есть невысокий крадус.
И отдельную какую-то модель физическую для взаимодействия вертикальных,
наклонно-правлив, горизонтальных скважин разрабатывать не надо.
Ну, не столько времени, во-первых.
Ну, и во-вторых, эта задача уже более такая узкая дальше будет.
Ее можно будет доточить уже под кейс, когда уже будет базовое взаимодействие межскважинное.
Так, потом шестой вопрос.
Стоимость текущего ремонта скважин при смене типоразмера и цен будет дана?
Она уже учтена вот здесь в экономике.
То есть, когда показывал.
Стоимость смены насоса.
Она уже здесь учитывается.
Сейчас покажу.
Да, вот смотрите.
Так, шрифт мелкий, конечно.
То есть, она здесь уже учитывается.
Установлены ЭЦН по типу размерам.
И вот здесь считается количество.
Количество ЭЦН.
20, 30, 50.
Ну, вот здесь она учитывается.
Здесь сильно симулятором было так задано, как ЭЦН.
Как ЭЦН, какие ЭЦН были заданы.
Не сильно большой диапазон.
Но, в принципе, табличка есть.
Режим работы скважин.
В каком диапазоне они работают, в принципе, до смены.
Так, что еще?
Седьмой вопрос.
ОПЕКС не связанный с ремонтом скважины.
Учитывать или считать постоянным?
Ну, здесь есть ОПЕКС, он из двух частей состоит.
Из постоянной части.
Это, который считается независимо от того, меняли вы насос, не меняли.
Он идет на жидкость и на закачку.
На количество скважин еще идет.
Два таких, ну, три таких параметра.
И переменные.
Это в зависимости от того, сделали вы смену насоса или не сделали.
То есть в таком виде.
То есть в этом случае стоимость выезда бригады, то есть она здесь постоянно цифры считается.
То есть поменяли насос, значит, надо бригаду на это посчитать.
Бригада у нас в ОПЕКСе считается.
И вот она туда ушла.
Экономика.
Вот.
Но не весь ОПЕКС не является константной.
То есть в зависимости от того, что за мероприятие.
То есть если вы по скважине ничего не делаете, там только идет постоянный ОПЕКС.
Так.
ОВН и ЭФ.
Восьмой вопрос.
Да.
Не надо углубляться в разные характеристики вытеснения.
То есть ободненность, водонефтяной фактор, динамика фронта.
Это уже в ходе расчета симулятора у вас получено будет.
Физика вытеснения, она точно также уже будет определена фильтрационными костными свойствами,
насыщенности, ОПП, вязкости, неодородности.
А ВНФ это больше подсвечивал как параметр для обучения агентов как, так скажем,
диагностический КПИ, так скажем,
который агент понимает, как этот ВНФ меняется, от чего он меняется,
какие параметры на него влияют.
То есть это как условно можно промежуточно учиться на жидкость.
Максимальная жидкость – это значит максимальная НФ, да?
Ну, как бы не всегда.
И когда вы это агенту объясните, от чего это зависит в ВНФ,
гораздо легче будет управлять системой.
Вот.
Это больше для того, чтобы понимать, что давать агенту для, так скажем, диагностических причин.
Так, по газовой шапке.
У нас это Black Oil.
То есть здесь газовой шапки нету.
Так, отдельно газовую шапку к объекту управления мы тоже не рассматриваем.
Растворенный газ и фазовое поведение при снижении давления,
оно будет учитываться в той же степени, как они заложены вот в Black Oil.
То есть, ну, больше ничего не нужно к этому учитывать, влияние там уделения газа.
Конечно, была мысль это сделать, добавить как еще одно осложнение.
Но, в принципе, если снижаться ниже давление насыщения,
хотя у нас там, ну, посмотрите, газовый фактор какой у этих,
то сразу там, например, задаваться по другой вязкости.
Но до такого уровня пока не делали, потому что, в принципе, задача и так непростая.
Я думаю, она так сильно творческая, как построить архитектуру мультиагентов,
с учетом всех прочих еще и разломов.
Разломы добавили вместо этого.
Поэтому с газом отдельными не возились.
Так, десятый вопрос.
Источник дополнительной воды или только подтоварная вода?
Так, у нас дополнительной воды здесь нету.
То есть вся вода, которую мы добыли, мы эту воду и закачиваем.
То есть в таком простом расчете.
То есть единый норматив, да, единый норматив закачки идет.
Ну, здесь уже не выберешь воду.
Сточную, пресную, такого здесь нету.
На самом деле, если будет решена сдача на том уровне, как сейчас она поставлена,
то, так скажем, усложнить ее, ну, несложно будет, да,
уже добавить какие-то новые водные, что у нас вода состоит из двух факторов.
Есть источная, есть товарная, есть там пресная для разных скважин, разных горизонтов, разная вода.
Но это уже будет чуть-чуть просто выше физико-ограничений больше.
Ну, вот оптимизационная задача, ну, и понимание просто, оно останется каким было.
Про ГРП.
Так, ГРП у нас нету.
Автогрп на скважинах тоже не моделируется.
То есть здесь на добывающем фонде во втором треке ГРП делали,
но больше мы не делаем, то есть продуктивность по нему по-любому не падает.
То есть как ГРП по истории сделали, все, ГРП больше там не делали.
В первом треке там все идеально, просто, и, в принципе, тоже ГРП делать не нужно.
Почему про ГРП отдельно говорю?
А, ну и вопрос такой задали.
Это, во-первых, перемены Капро, да?
Сейчас модели, я понимаю, получатся очень сильно синтетические, очень идеальные,
но мы и на датасетах таких создаем.
Но самое ключевое, что мы получим, что мы получим, это, в принципе,
архитектура мультиагентной сети, которая понимает пласт.
Вот это самое ядро, ради чего мы, в принципе, и хотим в рамках этих треков создать такие решения.
Ну а потом задать оптимизационную задачу для управления фондом.
Потому что все прочее, перемены Капро, там скользящим окном, это можно получить, в принципе.
Или, например, мы сделали ГРП, но потом в симулятор можно явно, не в симулятор, а в этот.
Агент можно сказать, вот такой скважины сделали ГРП,
переобучись вот на этом контуре, там, 500 метров, например, на этом радиусе, и все.
Это просто усложнение дополнительное будет, которое сейчас только спутать может.
Так, двенадцатый вопрос. Да, сейчас перевод добывающий скважины под ППД, возможно, только во втором треке.
В первом треке, так, как, в принципе, показывало здесь.
Ну, я уже это прошел, наверное, вопрос был до этого написан.
Да, в первом треке. Это будет все отдельно написано.
Во-первых, оно уже написано в правилах, чем можете управлять.
А во-вторых, еще в этом кейсе будет написано, когда техническое задание на кейс будет по тестовому заданию,
там будет написана ситуация, которая произошла на этом месторождении, и что нужно сделать, чем нужно управлять.
Так, пласт про тиригенный сказал.
Но литология вообще не закреплена.
Для упрощения постановки я просто сказал, что он больше к тиригенному относится.
Так, можно ли использовать циклику? Да, в обоих треках это и нужно делать.
Агенты и должны, в принципе, понять локально защемленные зоны и циклик ее вовлечь.
Аквифер во втором треке? В первом треке его нет, да.
В первом треке его нет, он только во втором треке.
Но и то он во втором треке задан не как на постоянное давление, как обычно считается.
Нет, у него есть свой мат-баланс, который вырабатывается у него.
То есть это сильно, так скажем, питающий пласт, так скажем, да.
То есть он не на постоянном давлении стоит и не ограниченный в воде.
Нет, у него поровая емкость ограничена, поровое пространство.
То есть он питает, наверное, первый там лет 5-6-7, вот так вот лет питает.
Я не смотрел, если честно, сколько он питает там активно, но он есть.
Он может и принять, может и отдать самые последние нижние слои в этом модели.
Вот. Так. В принципе, на этом вопросы все.
Так. Если вопросов больше нет, то, в принципе, можно закругляться.
Так. Григорий здесь?
Да.
У тебя там тоже были дополнения, да?
Добрый день, участники.
В целом я ничего демонстрировать не буду, а так вводную информацию озвучу.
Спасибо большое, Данил, за лекцию.
Еще раз.
В скором времени вам будет вывешена вся необходимая информация для выполнения
непосредственно задач нашего хакатона.
И также, как уже по старой практике, запись лекций плюс презентационные материалы.
Всех поздравляю с началом хакатона и желаю успехов.
А, еще забыл.
Также сегодня будет вывешен список распределения команд по трекерам,
которые будут вам помогать в реализации рабочих задач.
Также информация будет вывешена чуть попозже.
в 4.30 ориентировочно.
Мы должны к этому времени успеть.
У нас на этом все, да?
Я думаю, да.
Угу.
Что ж, всем еще доброго дня.
Все?
Все, спасибо.
Хорошего дня.
Угу.